good morning good afternoon and good
evening wherever you guys are at it's
your boys in here bringing you another
audio-ish review with a pair of
headphones that have hit home for me so
let's get into it
[Music]
this is the Invicta Satori gaming
headphones Satori means warrior and
Finnish and I have to say that these
pair of cans have a huge Legacy to
follow up to now a little bit about the
company Invicta is a new play on the
market under the wings of intracon and
intercon has decades worth of experience
when it comes to security corporate and
Military audio Hardware Solutions their
products range from the headsets that
people using call centers to the
headsets soldiers tank Crews and Pilots
use so these guys would know a thing or
two about keeping new audio files and
Gamers all day happy and honestly from
the getup I have right now I really like
my military stuff so let's open this bad
boy up
the sleeve feels very smooth however it
could use a little makeover with the
overall design because of the fonts
they're using and a little pop-up they
have going on down here but hey you
can't judge a book by its cover right I
mean honestly it's just a sleeve you
know it's adequate enough protection for
the main box which looks a lot better
and feels very robust now the whole
thing feels pretty light and Invicta
likes to talk about how light the
satori's are they kind of come in at 285
grams with their comfort light design so
these definitely look like a military
headset I can tell they took some
inspiration from introcon thx223s
ish however they're not the most
tactical looking because of the white so
in Victor if you're listening if you
guys release this in black olive green
khaki brown or coyote brown I would
definitely get this so for you guys
watching at home invictor has mentioned
to us that they will be releasing a
Bluetooth variant of these headphones in
due time so watch out for that and yeah
these things are really light and I've
had the chance to play with them for a
couple hours on Ghost Recon breakpoint
because you know tactical stuff and I
did not experience any kind of headset
fatigue as I like to call it where the
clamping Force starts to squeeze your
brains out and you gotta take a break
from these cans every once in a while
from start to finish I forgot they were
on me so honestly these things are Uber
comfy for your long nights of gaming
other things that come with the headset
is this Nifty little bag which is kind
of thin so if you're worried about your
headphones being damaged while they're
inside this thing don't because
literally military hardware way so it's
fine
so next up is the V command detachable
boom mic it is adjustable so you can
kind of push it away if you want to you
are on the receiving end of this mic
right now so you will sound nice bright
loud and clear as you chat with your
friends on Discord or use the voice chat
option in game so what comes next is the
transporter audio engine DSP USB sound
card oh that's a lot of words and it's
attached to a very lengthy durable as
heck braided sleeve cable also I forgot
to mention that the main cable on the
headphones is also braided so you don't
have to worry about the cables too much
of a dog or cat bites on them and I
really want a cat you can change the
volumes with the buttons here for your
mic and your headphones
you can change the EQ on the fly as well
as it comes in three different modes to
boost Clarity and bass
it's green for clarity red for Bass and
blue for a balanced EQ you have options
with this thing while the Satori is
definitely aren't super extensive when
it comes to EQ customization though they
may have something in the pipeline who
knows variety may be the spice of life
but Simplicity keeps the peace
now you have a comfortable pair of
headphones that you can game with for
hours on end and what you need next to
amp up that experience is a secret lab
chair this video is brought to you by
secret lab here at geek culture we love
our circular chairs especially the
all-new 2022 Titan Evo with its revamped
four-way lumbar system for enhanced back
support if PU leather 2.0 isn't your cup
of tea then consider the all-new soft
weave even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colors
including this lovely Frost blue the
Tyson Evo is even magnetized along the
head pillar to stick on the headrest of
course there are even more new features
so do check them out at secretlab.co
and the last thing that comes in the box
is
another box though this box may be
nothing special it is actually housing
something that you don't see very often
with other gaming headsets it's a nice
little add-on
it is a headphone stand
so Invicta initials you have some way
safe to keep your headphones on this bit
down here is made of rubber so it
doesn't tear into the leather padding
with any other kind of material
and look at that
wow to get into the specs this thing has
a frequency response of 20 Hertz to 20
kilohertz which is pretty much standard
across the market it uses a 15
millimeter driver and its independence
comes in at around 32 ohms Sound Stage
and imaging wise it hits a nice Middle
Ground of being white without losing too
much detail
So based on my experience with these
cans playing games like Ghost Recon
breakpoint Halo infinite and Battlefield
2042 I could clearly tell where the
enemy is firing and approaching from on
top of that I could definitely gauge how
far off or how close the enemies were in
terms of distance
and with all that said the satoris are a
very warm pair of headphones at least in
my opinion but they lean more towards
the brighter side of things because you
know Clarity is what they have and
Clarity is what you and I both want
because Clarity equals Intel equals
frags equals kills equals chicken
dinners even at the higher volumes the
satoris are not overwhelming at all
though that is very subjective because I
listen to everything in max volume
audiologists will come after me for
maximum Intel Gathering and immersion
these are operator s they're super comfy
Clarity is amazing and I could not
recommend these enough always remember
the Comfort levels and Clarity are all
that matter in Competitive Gaming so the
satori's check out major boxes in my
book that's all I have for them
victories are you gonna pick one up do
you have any questions that can help you
out with leave them all in the comment
section down below don't forget to
follow us on all of our socials and
remember to like subscribe and hit that
notification bell with a bunch of
content coming up
this is your boys in you going dark
[Music]